on the show you are a couple people seem
to root for you as a couple and you
guys play it up in public even though
you're not romantically
linked yes you do stop it yes
you do you like walk around you'll
you'll i've seen pictures of you where
you're
holding hands it's like you're taunting
the photographers
holding hands it's the same thing
and it sickens me you young people
now your fans are very serious they're
also very creative so they refer to
glenn and maggie a lot as
gleggy which sounds like a disease yeah
it's like it sounds like the scottish
word for phlegm
you know it's like uh you know it has a
it's a throw-up sound yeah it's a throw
up onomatopoeia yeah it's like ralphing
or like glow yeah
yeah do you like the name leggy are you
guys okay with that as being the both of
you as human beings being referred to
jointly as gleggy
the alternative we realized is man is it
men
men men is good with two ends
men that's good okay i guess that works
all right it makes no sense to me uh no
i think gleggy is better buggy's good
glad glady gleggy oh i don't know do you
have another one
i don't know what else it could be i
think it should be nothing to do with
either one of our names it should just
be like
yeah those two those two those two andy
and i together are conandy
or candy candy
[Applause]
let's change topics
on the show it was a big moment when you
guys had your first kiss huge moment
and we actually have a still from that
moment when your character's first kiss
now steven let's talk about your
technique
stephen do you see anything wrong there
right
looks it's pretty on point to me right
yeah pretty on point
is that now i'm hoping that's not your
in your private life your technique
that you keep your eyes open while
you're kissing
well okay this is the thing in that
moment glenn is confused because he's
like
this beautiful woman is about to kiss me
for like just being here
and so it's a shock to him and he keeps
his eyes open to make sure he
takes all of it in he's a participant
and an observer at the same time
[Applause]
he's just an efficient guy
yeah but if you had opened your eyes
there would have been no second kiss
what are you doing a guy i mean i just
the guy that's just like they're like i
am a participant and an observer
that's not creating a romantic and at
the end when i say to you were your eyes
open and you said no
now i know my bad